we want to tell you about a blunt
prediction this morning from California
governor Gavin Newsom he says a return
to life as normal in that state will not
happen anytime soon
hundreds of people protested California
state home restrictions at the State
Capitol in Sacramento yesterday but in
an interview you'll only see on CBS this
morning Newsom says more patience is
needed governor the last time you were
on our air
you said you worried people would become
fatigued with the social distancing
guidelines and the restrictions
it seems that fatigue has set in to
judge by the protests what's your
message to those protesters stay safe
stay healthy not only for yourselves but
your loved ones when you come home if
you haven't practiced physical
distancing be careful when you see
Grandma and Grandpa and focus again on
the fact that we're all in this together
President Trump has expressed sympathy
with the protesters even cheering them
on in some respects do you share that
sympathy if not exactly the president's
language well I share the empathy of
frustration that we're all living
through something we've never lived
through in our lifetime in the need and
desire for all of us to get back to work
into some semblance of normalcy can you
say from where you're sitting at this
moment that the worst is over in
California no because if we all pull
back we could see a second wave that
makes this pale in comparison I can't
say that honestly that's determined by
the act of 40 million Californians
stepping and continuing to meet this
moment I see you numbers are beginning
to flatten but we're not seeing yet the
significant decline that we need to see
ultimately to toggle back but we are
committed to a process we've socialized
that process and we are leaning in
working with 58 counties across the
state to make sure that we do it
together in a thoughtful and strategic
way I understand the timeline for easing
restrictions is still a work in progress
a little bit hazy it's dependent on what
people do today but from where you're
sitting with the data you have can you
say today that baseball is possible in
July school will be back in session in
September and it's possible that
elections will happen as normal in
November yeah I don't know I don't know
as normal and none of the above as
normal I think that would be unrealistic
to assert you have to radically change
the floor plans in the schools in
businesses private public institutions
large and small we're gonna have new
protocols and procedures temperature
checks people wearing face coverings
across the spectrum but the idea of tens
of thousands of fans coming together
across their differences high-fiving one
another hugging each other after a base
hit or a strike out is not something I'm
anticipating anytime soon it sounds like
what you're saying is life as we knew it
is gone until such a time when there's a
vaccine or herd immunity you got it I
mean it's not that complicated or
incredibly successful and viably
distributed treatments I don't
anticipate that normalcy that many of us
wish for happening anytime soon
but we will begin to toggle back to put
a little dimmer switch up and begin to
change the way we currently are
conducting ourselves from a full
lockdown stay at home order tube one
that is more prescriptive targeted and
strategized here you are preparing
people for profound changes I don't hear
the same message from Washington DC from
President Trump do you think he has a
responsibility at this point to start
preparing America for the very same
changes you've described I think we all
have a responsibility to use the
information that we have the data we
have and and and process it in a way
that's open and honest with the American
people look I don't think there's
anything wrong with being optimistic and
hopeful I'm optimistic I'm hopeful this
is not the new normalcy in perpetuity
we're gonna come back we just need to
temper the enthusiasm on when and how
and once we get hurt immunity and once
we get a vaccine then we could come back
and flourish and thrive boy but you know
herd immunity or a vaccine that could be
many months or more than a year off so
when it comes to being open and honest
with the American people the Governor of
California seems to be trying to do so
like many other governors he also said
he would like to see more federal
support in testing not with the
facilities they have enough facilities
what they lack gail is the supplies
swabs and the like you know you know
Tony what strikes me about the interview
that you just did was governor Newsom he
is certainly consistent last time he was
on our air
he said opening too soon would be like
jumping out of a plane with a parachute
and cutting the cord before you land a
lot of people thought that was a really
great analogy and the latest poll shows
that people hold on to what dr. Tony
pouchy says about when this should
reopen and he has said all along the
virus determines the timeline not
anybody else